ja sein harter Schnitt den wir machen
vom Thema Inflation und Energiekrise hin
zu einer anderen Krise die mich aber
wahnsinnig umtreibt es gab zu Beginn der
Woche eine wirklich dramatische Studie
die sich beschäftigt mit den Mathe und
Deutschkenntnissen der Schülerinnen und
Schüler in der vierten Klasse in
Deutschland da kam heraus dass die
Leistungen in die vergangenen fünf
Jahren deutlich nachgelassen haben immer
mehr Schüler haben Probleme die
Mindeststandards beim Rechnen und beim
Lesen in der vierten Klasse zu erfüllen
nicht nur Corona ist ausschlaggebend
gewesen sondern generell der Zustand
unseres nicht richtig guten Schulsystems
und das kann man natürlich auch
hochrechnen ökonome in dem Fall nicht
vom Institut für Weltwirtschaft in Kita
von ifo Institut aus München haben das
gemacht und haben festgestellt
schwächere Bildung lernverluste sorgen
dafür dass man über sein Leben ein
geringeres Erwerbseinkommen hat also
weniger verdient und natürlich das
Wirtschaftswachstum am Land auch viel
geringer ausfällt das sind alles keine
wirklich guten Nachrichten das ist
glaube ich ein Alarmsignal was
Wiedersehen das heißt wir müssen weg von
dem Experimentieren weg von solchen
ideologischen Dingen auch wie das
Schreiben nach Gehör sondern wieder hin
zu einem klassischen Schulbetrieb zu
einem leeren und einem Lernenden sonst
steht es um unser Land die Zukunft
dieses Landes nicht besonders gut Herr
Rosen sie jetzt Kinderarzt haben viel
Kontakt mit Kindern was ist da los
ich habe Kontakt im Kindern die meine
Praxis kommen da kriege ich natürlich
viel vom Bildungssystem mit ich habe
einen differenziertes Bild vom
Bildungssystem ich sehe die Probleme die
sie auch angesprochen haben bin da auch
größtenteils da core dass wir wirklich
ein großes Problem haben in Deutschland
was nicht nur auf die corona-pandemie
geschoben werden kann ganz klar es war
noch mal großes Problem in den letzten
Jahren aber das Problem hat ja vorher
schon angefangen ich sehe aber auch dass
das Schulsystem lernfähig ist dass wir
viele Leute viele Kinder mittlerweile in
diesem Schulsystem viel besser abholen
als das noch der Fall war als ich zum
Beispiel zur Schule gegangen bin wo es
damals es gab diese Einrichtung für
schwererziehbare Kinder es gab
einfach diesen Begriff das sind Kinder
die sind im Schulsystem Inklusion nicht
nur Inklusion sondern eine
differenziertere Betrachtung von Bedarf
und differenzierte Förderung früher war
das Kind schwer erziehbar heute guckt
man genauer hin mit Fachlehrern mit
förderlehrern die gucken warum ist das
Kind schwer erziehbar hat vielleicht ein
Aufmerksamkeitsdefizit Käse
rechtschreibstörung hat es vielleicht
ein intelligenzmangel ist gar nicht an
der falschen an der richtigen Schulform
und diese Differenzierung führt dazu
dass viele Leute die damals durch dieses
Raster gefallen wären jetzt viel besser
anhand Ihrer individuellen Möglichkeiten
gefördert werden können was nicht
bedeutet dass das Gesamtschulsystem
dadurch massiv besser geworden ist die
Leistung ich glaube da muss man nicht
drüber reden sind verbesserungswürdig
aber das ist das differenzierte mit
einem Paradoxon zu tun hier sitzen
Ökonom am Tisch deswegen Paradoxon 1 die
Leistungen der Schüler werden schlechter
Paradoxon 2 auch im internationalen
Vergleich übrigens das sehen wir ja das
geht eher wieder zurück nach dem ersten
Pisa-Schock wird wieder schlechter
paroxon 2 immer mehr Leute in
Deutschland machen Abitur und haben auch
eine einsform Komma also das klappt
auseinander international werden wir
maximal gleich gut oder schlechter aber
im nationalen Vergleich immer mehr
Einser Abiturienten das heißt auch da
lügen wir uns eigentlich ordentlich was
in die Tasche von Inflationen
ich glaube ja Monster was vorlegen Lügen
ich glaube aber auch den Forschern am
Ifo-Institut die Sie gerade schon
zitiert haben die sagen wir setzen
falsche Prioritäten der tertiäre Sektor
und die Universitäten werden bei uns zu
sehr gepäppelt also während wir in der
frühkindlichen Bildung und in der
kitaphase zu wenig tun und das ist nicht
nur eine Frage des Geldes aber eben auch
das Geldes es ist aber auch und da gibt
es gute Vorbilder aus Amerika Förderung
von Kindern und Eltern also gerade nicht
separieren und dann meinen Eltern liegen
kann in Deutschland das ist ganz ganz
eindeutig und da jetzt diese Studie die
ja Mathe und
schreibkenntnisse als nochmals
schlechter
herausbekommen hat hat jetzt zugleich
auch gesagt es liegt natürlich auch an
der Migration und das ist ja
andererseits toll dass wir Migranten
Kinder in das Schulsystem in die Bildung
integrieren und ihnen damit zukunfts-
eröffnen die sie nicht gehabt hätten
aber das würden wir besser hinbekommen
wenn wir hier noch stärker eine
verzahnte Förderung von Kindern und
Eltern geht es vor allem im
Sprachkenntnisse aber es geht auch um
kulturelle Kenntnisse vermitteln würden